it seems we haven't measured almost all
of our lives when we are infants with
our height and our weight and as we grew
it became our speed and our strength and
even in school our test scores and today
with our salaries and job performance it
seems as if those personal averages are
almost always used to measure where we
are in comparison to our peers and I
think we should look at that a little
differently that personal average is
just that it's something very personal
it's for you and I think if you focus on
that and work to build that you can
really start to accomplish some really
amazing things this idea started for me
on a December evening in 2011 I just
stepped outside to do our evening chores
to feed our horses I hopped into our
tractor and a few minutes later a five
foot tall
700 pound bale of hay fell from the
loader crushing me in the seat of the
tractor in their process shattering my
t5 and t6 vertebrae I didn't lose
consciousness but I felt this buzz
throughout my body and I knew what had
happened right away my hands were
reaching for my legs but my legs didn't
recognize anything touching them and in
fact I couldn't feel anything from the
center of my chest down so there I was
about 100 feet from the house with my
arms wrapped around the steering wheel
trying to hold myself up waiting for
help and unlike what you see in TV in
the movies as much as I try to get the
dogs to go to the house and get help
they just stared at me
well 45 minutes later my wife came home
and I heard her step out of the house
and and like normal if I needed help hey
do you need help and I said yes and
there's a brief pause and then I heard
her yell geenie 9-1-1 help and again I
yelled yes well not long after I was
enjoying my very first helicopter ride
all the way to the hospital now the
injury wasn't very dramatic or graphic I
simply broke a bone or two and in the
process I was told I'd probably never
walk again it became very normal for me
to use a rope to sit up in bed because
my abdominal muscles no longer work or
to use a board to slide
to bed into a wheelchair or to even wait
for people to reach things for me
everything that I had learned and had
known about my height and my strength
and my balance and my mobility was blown
away my entire personal average had been
reset now you can be sure in those days
I was being measured more than ever but
that doctors and nurses for sure but
maybe more so in my own mind and I found
myself comparing what I thought I was
going to be able to do going forward
with what I once was able to do and I
became pretty frustrated it took some
very consistent prodding for my wife
kept saying get your eyes up before I
could get moving forward and I soon
realized that I almost had to forget
about the person I was before and the
things I was able to do before I almost
had to pretend it was never me and I'm
afraid if I had not made that
realization my frustration would have
turned into something much harder to
recover from now luckily a few weeks
later I was transferred to a specialty
spinal cord rehab hospital about ten
hours from home and wouldn't you know
the first day of rehab in the first
session we had something called fit
class and a group of us broke into teams
to see which team could do the most reps
in the weight machine now we've all been
there haven't been to the gym in a year
or two and neither had I and so what do
you do you try to do what you did a
couple of years ago I need to do a
couple of sets and then what do you do a
couple more and you're feeling even
better so you do more and the next two
weeks you complain to your family about
how sore you are well my team went all
out and we won we won big and for the
next three days I could not straighten
my arms which isn't that big a deal
except when you're in a wheelchair and
that's really what you have to use to
get around and that proved to be a very
important lesson for me you know it was
one thing that I couldn't compare myself
to myself but even around people in the
same situation in that hospital I found
that I couldn't try to keep pace or set
pace with them as well and I was left
with really only one choice and that was
to focus on who I was at that point in
time with where I needed to go and to
get back to who I needed to be for their
next six weeks for seven to eight hours
a day that's what I did I built little
by little
and as you might expect when you're
recovering from a spinal cord injury
you're gonna have a bad day you might
have a few in a row and what I found out
is that good and bad really didn't have
a lot of meaning unless I had the
context of knowing what my average was
it was really up to me to decide if
something was bad or good based on where
I was at that point in time it was in my
control to determine if it really was a
bad day if I get was my decision on
whether or not I could stop a streak of
bad days and what I found during that
time away from home is that never had a
bad day even with everything going on
there were parts of my day that were
certainly not as pleasant as they could
be that was never an entirely bad day so
I'm guessing all of you have been
through a meeting that probably didn't
go very well or a commute that wasn't as
great as you would like it or even
burned dinner at night then those things
really ruined your entire day what I
found in those scenarios is the quicker
you move on to what's next the quicker
you can start attacking things and by
moving on the next as fast as possible
you shrink the time you spend in those
bad scenarios and it gives more time for
the good and as a result the good
outweighs the bad
your average increases and that's just
how the math works it didn't matter to
me if I had spent the morning really
struggling with my medication or at
lunch my legs being very or even
if I had fallen out of my wheelchair
asked my wife it happens quite often
she's here
there were just small parts of my day in
small parts of my average and so on the
months and years that followed I
continued to try to attack things in
that way and before I know what I was
being presented with some pretty
incredible challenges like completing a
marathon and wheelchair in early 2016 I
met my physical therapists and after a
few really grueling sessions she must
have sensed something because she pulled
me aside and said you know you should do
a half marathon in your wheelchair oh
yeah it's in ten weeks and I thought in
my mind you're crazy I didn't have a
workout plan I didn't have any way of
knowing how fast I needed to go or how
far I was supposed to go
but I simply got to work and I started
tracking every workout every day and I
simply wanted to be as good as or as
fast as I was the prior day and in the
end I really created that average for
myself and I tried to build on that as
much as I could
well I finished that race right in time
with what my average should have been
and you know somewhere along the way I
kind of close the door and who I once
was that person who I was before and all
those things I thought I was able to do
it really didn't matter in fact walking
again really didn't matter became much
less of a goal for me in terms of where
I was gonna go and besides you guys are
so slow what you walk I mean in crowds
like this it is so difficult might get
out of the way we're going places and
all I wanted to do is go fast so I did
what I thought I should do I started
researching wheelchair racing and I went
online and I found the best of the best
I learned their technique I learned
about the equipment and I was lucky to
have a coach that offered me a way to
get started and after talking with him
and having helped me get get those
things you know underway as I was
leaving he says you know you should do
the 2017 Chicago Marathon and you know
he's the coach I can't tell him no so
with that guidance I went back home and
I got to work much like in the prior
prior way and I continued researching
but I had learned my lesson I was really
careful not to compare with how
accomplished those people on the
internet were and how fast they were
because if I had then I probably never
would have continued going through with
it well the weekend of the race arrived
you know it's just like going to college
for the first time you're dumped off
there's a whole bunch of people around
you you don't really know very many of
them somebody's got the cool stereo and
the cool TV and they're smart and
they're pretty and they're cute and
they're handsome and you don't know if
you really belong but then somebody says
hey let's go get food and all of a
sudden that friend group happens and you
start to settle in
well that weekend of the race we had a
meeting called the wheelers meeting and
there were 60 wheelchairs in that room
the night before the race and once you
know it all of the people that I had
been researching over there
the best of the world there must have
been over 50 Paralympic medals in the
room that day and I felt pretty small
and I fell back into that trap of
comparing myself I knew that my averages
that I had been tracking you during my
workouts for over 90 seconds slower per
mile than theirs and the coach was the
only one there that I knew and he
reached out and noticed something and I
think he sensed my anxiety and he
invited me to get food with his team and
with that everything settled down I
realized really quick that they didn't
care about my average surely and I had
forgotten about theirs well that next
day I finished the race about 45 minutes
after the person that wanted but as I
was leaving those new friends who are
very close today challenged me to stay
involved and to keep working through
different races and competitions and so
I did what I knew how I went home and I
got busy now as you can imagine being in
a wheelchair let alone training for a
marathon or wheelchair is a pretty
lonely thing I have an incredible group
of friends that will ride bike with me
and keep track of pace and help me out
but in the end it's still five to six
days a week it's 50 to 60 miles of
effort and there's a lot of alone time
and for the most part you really have
nothing to rely on but yourself in those
times
it's my average and I'm trying to get
better little by little
well this falls in Chicago for the third
time it was my seventh marathon and just
like going back to college for your
junior year you're anticipating catching
up with friends and getting excited
about rolling right back into things
well I attended the same pre-race
meeting in the same pre-race meal and
caught up with those friends and we
lined up for the race and right at the
start my average kicked in and before
long I caught up with some of those
friends was able to keep pace with them
and push together but it wasn't long
before I faded it just happened and I
found myself all alone again with really
nothing to rely on other than what I had
worked so hard to be you know be out but
we turned into the wind at the halfway
point and my average became a really
strong advantage and it wasn't long
before I actually caught some of those
friends and passed them all the way to
the finish
and while I didn't set a personal record
that day I did finish 30 seconds per
mile faster than my prior Chicago times
and just left myself pretty excited and
so this is me this is my average 75 days
from today I'll be in Boston for my
second time I'm super excited about that
but keep in mind this isn't really just
about racing right I'm working really
hard every day to be better in so many
other ways a better parent better
husband better coach teammate friend
person and I promise you even though
what you see here is very visible in
terms of the challenges that I face
everybody here has something that are
fighting and it may be visible may not
be but please take some time and focus
on you instead of others and I bet you
can win those challenges and really
start accomplishing so many great things
thank you
[Applause]